i can't work out if we're closer to 1984
or a brave new world
it feels like some awful love child
of both so i think it's brave new world
i agree
yes idiot but it's not a love child like
50 50. no you know sometime in the
future they're going to figure out how
to engineer our dna
so we're only like 10 this guy and 30
this guy and
disc or whatever i think it's about 10
percent george orwell
specifically because of the language
focus of the radicals
but i think it's about 90 percent uh
huxley because huxley and huxley
actually made this point to orwell
because huxley was orwell's teacher
french teacher french teacher right yes
i think so
and so read the book read the book
michael yeah that's right yeah truly i'm
i'm so
honored uh because you've read the book
now probably more recently than i have
so you could probably tell me things
about the
yeah maybe but yes huxley was was
orwell's french teacher
and he said you know george you're your
dystopia is fine the language stuff is
good
but you think that the totalitarian
government is going to rule with an iron
fist
and it's going to you know take away all
people's sorts of pleasures and
but no actually what's going to happen
is
the the totalitarian government is going
to rule by
by playing to people's pleasures by
getting people so
drugged up on actual drugs that by
getting people so
over sexed with casual non-committed
sex that they're totally outside of
their faculties of reason
and they're they're susceptible to being
controlled and when you look around our
society today
worst opioid crisis we've ever seen
you know marriage rates in the doldrums
but people having creepy sex you know
all over the place doing all sorts of
things
with any number of people and and that
being normalized uh
we're seeing that and we're seeing the
the idea normalized that any sort of
sacrifice any sort of burden any sort of
suffering
is wicked and evil and has to be
overcome so that we can just
pursue our passion you do you don't yuck
my yum this kind of language i mean
that's the language
of huxley's world state that is not the
language of
of orwell's big brother even if you
think about what social media is doing
right it's an
internal it's a systemic rather than
exogenous
way to manipulate the chemicals that
you've got in your body immediate
guilt-free pleasure uh the same goes
from amazon you know you can
amazon prime yourself a lovely new item
that will give you that hit while you
doordash or deliver a michelin star meal
while you sit on the couch and watch
million dollar produce
tv shows on netflix it's it really is um
yeah for all of human history we've had
problems of scarcity right and now our
problems are problems of abundance
and i think you're right i think that
1984
might have happened if technology hadn't
enabled brave new world
without the technology i don't think the
brave new world can happen because
you re it requires such sophisticated
coordination it requires
um a degree of siloing of information
whilst also free
free communication across that and the
levels of
comfort and convenience that are
required in order to enact a brave new
world you need to have
here's the thing right so i think about
this to do with existential crises all
the time
how luxurious of a position it is to
have an existential crisis
because the only way that you can get to
that situation is if the bottom levels
of maslow's hierarchy of needs have all
been sorted
so much like if you're worried about
where the next meal is coming from you
don't have the luxury to concern
yourself about whether
you are contributing to your own highest
good within the world right
um so yes brave new world i'm i'm i'm
with you on that 9010 it's a language
from
1984 and everything else from brave new
world except for the soma
which was still yet to get except for
the soma although i don't i guess
oxycontin or something is the soma now
and i
i think that this issue of that
existential enui
people who work a lot don't have
existential on we because they're busy
working
they have they have needs to meet and
and beyond that by the way it's not even
just
that we don't work enough or we're all
telecommuting or something it's
uh because there are plenty of people
who can't telecommute i mean this was
one of the arguments
uh for the lockdowns as all the genius
experts said oh no you can work on zoom
and i said oh right you none of you know
people who work physical jobs
so you don't you think that everybody
can just telecommute in on zoom
actually believe it or not there's some
people who do real things in real way
until you need your plumbing fixing via
zoom yeah exactly
that's right yeah yeah that's right get
the electrician in on zoom it's not
gonna work very well
um so yes you've got this problem of of
abundance
and the the chemical aspect of social
media is
is pretty clear too the one that i get
sucked into
is twitter i'm on twitter a lot i'm just
the one i don't do
facebook as much i don't do instagram
but twitter i do and i was talking to a
friend of mine he said why are you on
twitter so much
and just came out of me i said because i
don't want to look at porn
so i don't i if i don't want to look at
porn i still want to get the same sort
of you know
pleasure of oxytocin whatever and so now
instead i'm just getting sort of
political
you know rage tweets or something but
everybody seems to be hooked on these
things and
for a lot of people i suppose it it is
literally porn right it's not even just
which is which is this other issue of uh
of abundance right i mean truly that
there you know if you can think of it
there's a porn for it
and i think it's why you're seeing a
reaction among younger conservatives you
know there was a big debate that busted
out
um in partaking in some ways of the pc
debate because we do have laws against
obscenity and yet they don't really seem
to be enforced very much with porn
and the debate to ban porn or not or to
regulate porn
you would imagine it would be the old
fuddy duddies or against porn
and the young you know rap scallions are
for porn but actually it was totally
reversed
the people defending porn were the
boomers the boomers who were using this
kind of
pseudo quasi libertarian language of the
80s and 90s
and saying oh well you know if it feels
good do it and the younger people
who grew up on this stuff who i think
that the median age of of porn exposure
for boys is like 11 years old or
something
and they were saying no man this is
really bad stuff it's kind of messed me
up it's hard to work through
like how are we not regulating this and
you know that they are obviously much
more in tune
with political reality than these p then
these throw your hands up conservatives
who get rid of all the standards i'm so
glad i don't know
by what quirk of this version of the
simulation i managed to avoid a porn
addiction
but i'm so glad that that's not one of
you know of all of the vices and
and odd quirks and behavioral problems
that i've managed to
sidestep through life i'm really glad
that porn addiction isn't one of them
because it's so inconvenient
and i suppose it's it's just available
all the time but you know part of it
might just be
that if you're a millennial you've kind
of just missed it or you know maybe
it was it was still there i guess when
we were kids but but you still think
you're right
dial up internet but but think about if
you're a zoomer right think about if
you're a kid who right now is 18 years
old or something
you have had some kind of high speed
device in your hand
from the time you were like three and
and so
your your brain just isn't built for
that and and it's
you know i think it also gets a little
bit too competing
theories of the mind you know there's
this one theory of the mind which is
that our mind is like a
a steam engine or something you know and
we've got uh
we've got to just let it out we don't
want to repress anything we've just
gotta
if you blow off a little steam you'll
you'll feel great and then you can go on
you said that sorry to interject there
you said that this
aligned with the technologies of the day
right you kind of
had these different sections who was it
that was the steam
thing was that so so coincidentally
you've got sort of freud coming up
around the same time as as the steam
engine right and
so freud is uh you know and freudianism
kind of leads to this idea that you
shouldn't
you've got all these repressed desires
and feelings and
thoughts and you've got to just sort of
let them out and and then you'll have a
much healthier society and and
and you then see this expressed in the
kind of kooky theories of guys like
wilhelm reich
who who believed that the the life
force the life energy was something
called the orgone this esoteric
particle and the the cause of war and
cancer and death and everything
was a lack of orgasms and so a little
bit more masturbation fixes a lot of
problems michael
yes no i mean this is truly what what
the left is saying now and you'll you'll
see it being taught in kids cartoons
they'll say you know it's perfectly
healthy it's totally right
to uh in the words of woody allen have
sex with someone you love
alone in a room you know you're the one
person you know you love
um it's perfectly good that it's very
healthy you've got to do that
during the lockdown the new york city
health department was saying oh
yeah you can't hook up right now but
you've basically you've got to go you
know turn the blinds down and have fun
with yourself
whenever you can but this is actually
the opposite of healthy right
the traditional view is that virtues
and vices are habits and the more you do
them
the more you do them so you i mean you
make this point where you say i'm glad i
never developed
a porn addiction well i suspect part of
the reason you didn't is because
when we grew up it was you know it just
wasn't quite as available but if
if you had you know it had a device in
your hand at three years old and and you
were just doing this constantly
it would be very difficult to break that
switch i would rather than just
pathological
yes that's right on your business card
is what i would say
i mean this sort of you know i think
people are beginning
to recognize this a little bit more
especially as we as we become more
digitized as we live more of our lives
virtually
as we are zooming in to our friends and
our work and our parties and things
we realize as as the language of
universalism has taken over the language
of nation or country
we're beginning to realize wait a second
i'm a i do have a body
i am in time and space i know i'm told
that my identity has nothing to do with
my body
but i think maybe i do and you know i
think it's why jordan peterson
has become so popular and resonates so
well as he says hey
clean your room the things you do
actually actually do matter
and one of the really insidious aspects
of political correctness
is that political correctness takes old
moral codes
and replaces them with new speech codes
so it matters less and less and less
what you do
and more and more and more what you say
it's this you know we've kind of created
this
this prison of our own minds and that
that way lies madness
thank you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that then press here
for the full unedited episode and don't
forget to subscribe
makes me very happy indeed peace